I just saw Brent and it's so funny when
he ran for City Council down in Florida
he had a television commercial I guess
that ran locally and I was watching it
and he's wearing these dark sunglasses
he looks like a guy who just got out of
jail personal he's very pasty and white
yes no hair so he looks like mr. freeze
but let me ask you something did he have
any kind of a political consultant no I
said that's what happens when you run a
one-man campaign he goes well he goes
the reason I wear sunglasses when I shot
the commercial was sunny outside ago it
doesn't matter for a minute don't wear
[ __ ] sunglasses if you listen
carefully during the commercial it's you
don't want a carousel when they run out
of music and it just starts up again
that's a little loop yeah loop you'll
hear the loop like you'll hear this
splice in the tape ladies and gentlemen
my name is Brent Handley and I'm running
for st. Petersburg City Council District
three one of the things I feel strongly
about is the rule of law John Adams said
it best this is a government of laws and
not of men and the great dr. Martin
Luther King said darkness cannot drive
out darkness
can do that and that's what I'm gonna
proponent for is government in the
sunshine full transparency give all the
music is drowning them out
it's barely why is he screaming over the
news wait wait wait you'll hear the loop
soon
respect for your rights we live in a
constitutional republic that demands
your participation remember to vote
November 8th and vote print Hatley city
council district 3 I'm Bradley and I
approve this message
[Music]
no ii take with this guy i mean that was
definitely his first i mean it almost
sounded like he hadn't read what he was
gonna read brent did anybody like talk
to you and say hey this commercial makes
you look a little weird yeah that was a
it was terrible and why is the mix on
the music so hot i don't know i didn't
do any of the video productions did you
look at it afterwards i did and by the
way you could do a much better read than
that you've been in radio yes what
[Music]
what I always say that Martin Luther
King said whatever darkness there is
also
[Music]
I
[Music]
my name is Brett
terrible you look like a mafia hit man
in that [ __ ] commercial I'm not
making a joke I mean I was like you're
running for office and you dress
yourself up like sort of like the Blues
Brothers yeah you should be delivering a
threat because you're calculating kind
of guy did you ever calculate how many
votes that commercial cost you no I did
not I won the debates though hi I'm Brie
I got to tell you
[Music]
this is actually an exercise space guys
what
[Music]
hi I'm Brent Hadley my entire childhood
I had a dream of making a really shitty
commercial and now my dreams come true I
was in radio for 30 years and goop done
[ __ ] like this but somehow when I made
my own commercial I [ __ ] it all up
here's a fact Brent got 6126 votes in
that election yeah that's amazing
he would've had 10,000 but then he put
out that commercial 12 he got 11 or 12
on yeah all I know is the guy who was
running against him when he saw this
commercial he started doing back flips
because that's it I don't care if I win
it debate [ __ ] were you thinking I
obviously was not thank Jesus
all right Bronte well I do make some
huge
[Music]
you were this close to weapon
[Music]